[Music]
for as long as I can remember I have
loved election day when I was a kid I
used to follow my parents into the
voting booth pushing each little red
button with intense focus after we got
home my parents and I would sit in the
kitchen and talk about how there are
small decisions and those little buttons
linked to big decisions happening at the
highest levels of government on my 10th
birthday my grandfather gave me a blank
index card and told me to write the top
five things that I wanted to be when I
grew up next to teacher and ballerina I
wrote that I wanted to work at the White
House now maybe this was because I grew
up in a family that watched the West
Wing every week but I like to think that
it's because of all of those times that
I'd followed my parents into the voting
booth my grandfather took that index
card dated it and sealed it in an
envelope which I promptly forgot about
but I found that envelopes stuffed in
the back of a bookshelf 14 years later
one month after being offered a job at
the White House now anyone who knows me
could tell you that my childhood love of
government has only grown and to this
day I do still love to vote but most
people don't share my enthusiasm in fact
voter turnout in US midterm elections
tends to hover just below 40% if someone
can win with the plurality of the votes
that means that they can get elected to
lead with the support of less than 20%
of their constituents now you may be
asking why does this matter for me I
want you to take a moment and think of
the products and services that you use
everyday who provides them raise your
hand if you're thinking of a big tech
company right now okay most of us now
raise your hand if you're thinking of
government one or two but you've got
some work to do I've had a lot of
conversations
my peers here at business school about
the role of government and many people
have expressed that they don't see any
connection between the actions they take
and the outcomes the government provides
but in reality the work of government
touches each of our lives in countless
ways that go beyond the headlines every
single day let's take a look at your day
today your alarm goes off you look at
the clock and get out of bed you check
your favorite weather app and maybe take
a morning medication let's say that you
scroll through notifications on your
iPhone while eating your breakfast and
decide to Google a particularly
interesting news story before moving on
with your day let's recap what just
happened who's at the time on your alarm
clock the National Institute of
Standards and Technology a US government
agency your weather app is pulling data
from the National Weather Service and
that medication why did you assume that
it's safe and effective because
consciously or not you have faith in the
work of the Food and Drug Administration
as for that iPhone do you know who
provided the early stage financing for
Apple the US government small business
investment company program venture
capitalist only started to take note
after government funding got Apple too a
proof of concept and as for that Google
search of the morning headline it was
possible in no small part because of the
National Science Foundation which funded
the early work on Google's algorithm a
lot of people here in Silicon Valley see
government as red tape and regulations
but that overlooks the massive role that
government has played in spurring some
of our most disruptive innovations in
many ways the work of government is the
invisible thread holding the fabric of
society together
we haven't even left your house yet in
the example that I just walked through
and there are millions of lives even
more intimately touched by government
every day
through things like unemployment
insurance health care and public
education
but while its work touches each of our
lives every day whether we know it or
not too many of us remain uninterested
in the public sector now I recognize
that government is not perfect there are
many improvements to be made in terms of
efficiencies and user experience let
alone tangible policy outcomes but in
the same way that public companies need
shareholders to provide accountability
and counsel government needs
shareholders too and that comes in the
form of active civic engagement there
are countless ways to get involved but
the one that tends to come up the most
is voting now for any of you who may
still be on the fence about the value of
voting I could give you an impassioned
plea about how it's your duty given
those who fought for your right to enter
the voting booth I could tell you about
the importance of having a
representative sample of the population
vote so that our elected officials are
actually representative of the general
public and for the more data-driven
members of the audience I could tell you
that if you are in a swing state the
chance of your one vote changing the
election outcome is actually 18 times
better than your chance of winning the
lottery
but beyond emotional and data-driven
appeals I would propose that there are
two main reasons why it's crucial that
you vote first oftentimes there are many
things to vote for on a ballot beyond
just people especially here in
California in this November's midterms
there were eleven different statewide
propositions on California ballots
soliciting constituent input on
everything from affordable housing to
whether or not California should abandon
daylight savings time and these measures
often do pass or fail on very thin
margins second politicians look at who
votes whether or not you vote is a
public record here in the United States
and that means that yes your neighbors
can know whether or not you voted in the
most recent elections but more
importantly it means the politicians
knew
voted and who did not and especially at
the local level when those same
politicians are making decisions about
different policies down the line for
better for worse they look at who voted
last time as the projection for who's
likely to vote next time that means that
if you want to be sure that your
interests are heard in how your
government operates you have to take on
the mantle of being an active citizen
now for those of you who already vote
government doesn't only need you on
Election Day there's a whole spectrum of
ways to get involved the rest of the
year
from calling your elected official and
expressing support or concern for an
issue to volunteering for a local or
national campaign that you're excited
about or getting involved in political
tech and creating a digital solution to
help government better serve the public
maybe you help fund public private
partnerships to drive forward meaningful
social change or maybe you even decide
to run for office or otherwise do a tour
of duty of sorts in government yourself
today roles in government are no longer
limited to policy advisor project
coordinator and legislative director
today roles in government include
becoming a presidential innovation
fellow a user experience designer or
even chief technology officer of the
United States these are all real roles
that real people hold in government and
all of them have been held by someone
who decided to leave Silicon Valley for
a few years and contribute their time
and talents to the change that they
wanted to see toward the end of my time
at the White House I found myself
standing outside the Oval Office waiting
to begin my farewell meeting each
staffer gets with the president I was
trying to remember to breathe as I
nervously counted the Stars and Stripes
on the lapel pin of the Secret Service
Officer across from me before I knew it
a staffer said next and ushered me into
the Oval Office where Barack Obama was
standing in front of the resolute desk
now I had played this moment over
and over in my mind I would thank him
and explain what an honor it was to
contribute in even a small way to his
legacy and he would thank me and
congratulate me for my work but what I
remember most from our conversation that
day is what President Obama said at the
end we shook hands to say goodbye and he
paused and said there's more work to be
done not thank you for what you have
done and not congratulations but there's
more work to be done there I was
expecting to celebrate the team's
accomplishments to date only to have the
leader of the free world remind me of
the never ending list of problems yet to
be solved and that is a huge challenge
but it's also a huge opportunity and one
in which all of us can play a part you
may have heard john f kennedy's quote
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
but I don't think that's quite right yes
you should ask what you can do for your
country
but you should also never stop asking
what your country can do for you because
if we start thinking about that if we
start expecting more and seeing
ourselves as shareholders in government
then we can truly bring our government
to its fullest potential together
because in the end there's always more
work to be done thank you
[Applause]
[Music]